many German banks have yet to see the
writing on the wall a new generation of
technology customers and competitors
we want to be the Pirates of banking
welcome um you are the Pirates of
banking there is a need for new banking
as the web 2.0 development showed us
there is a potential for new banking I
would say this is kind of a typical high
street banker you know steering his old
crappy bank through the wilderness and
storm of this event which he by the way
cost himself fighting words for the
financial sector one year into the 2008
financial crisis matías crona's
internet-based feed or bank opened for
business debunk nom in tanks are facing
the problem of this rapid technology
development the world over digital
natives are coming of age so we need new
banking worldwide but instead of big
institutional structures and expensive
advisors developers and bankers at
cheaper locations collaborate on mobile
banking systems the concept is that
future banking customers will use the
Internet to exchange ideas with others
and will want to manage their money
easily and directly with our service you
can send money from one account to an
email address or a mobile phone number
or receive tips on saving you can count
on support for money matters that's
extremely important to us with only 60
thousand accounts matthias quanah's
internet bank is still getting up to
speed it's as yet no match for the likes
of Google or other Internet giants
Facebook hudna Bank Utzon Facebook has a
banking license and the industry is
talking about Apple already being the
biggest financial service provider in
the world with over 400 million banking
profiles I never did believe that the
regulator's would only protect the bank
but leave an Internet company out in the
cold they get their licenses straight
away and their focus is elsewhere it's
clearly about who communicates best with
their customers but many savings and
loans private banks and customers remain
skeptical especially in Germany
one out of two customers come to their
branch in person to do their banking the
conventional way his comets Bank
Germany's second largest bank worried
about the new digital based competition
if you named no but of course we're
watching the market trend very closely
and we'll be responding to it that's why
we're stating very clearly that we're
investing in online capacities but at
the same time in our network of branches
I think that's an asset that Komets Bank
has that other players may not be able
to offer at least in this form the trend
seems to be heading towards fewer
brick-and-mortar branches and more
cutting-edge service among Komets banks
digital gimmicks and gadgets of video
teller to walk customers through their
banking transactions and new online
banking platforms
Fedora and other up-and-coming banks are
already looking abroad today developers
and investors have come from Moscow
matías Rona is planning a subsidiary in
Russia a German financial sector is a
very conservative and even in some
African countries like Kenya there are
several generation Father then the
current German situation with financial
services but nevertheless I will say
that you can make some offensive things
but this is nevertheless this is money
this is banking and you customers expect
some trust feed or bank will soon be
making its British debut as well and
like in Russia now we started with the
community first and then there was the
banking offer coming in the second step
these bankers are confident that even
Germany's digital sceptics are beginning
to sense the changes the Information Age
means for banking they are really
getting nervous I can tell you